[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[за підтримки «Лавка Традицій».
Продукти від маленьких господарств]
[Іскрівка,
Подніпров'я і Запоріжжя]
Червоненькі — гарненькі.
Так, буквально ще днів десять,
я думаю, він почне червоніти.
А не буде такого, що він у якийсь сонячний день
почервоніє дві тонни за раз?
Може бути таке?
Навіть якщо він і почервоніє за день дві тонни,
він на кущі не буде пропадати,
він просто буде висіти,
ви собі будете брати за потреби.
Я завжди хотів робити щось унікальне —
[Роман Мартинов
Підприємець]
те, що ніхто не робить, і ми такі:
«Опа! А як вам такий продукт?
А що ви скажете про це?»
Щоб був wow-ефект,
щоб людям було цікаво.
І ми займаємося разом із сім'єю
виробництвом натуральних соусів.
[Маргарита Мартинова
Підприємиця]
Нас відрізняє склад, нас відрізняють цінності.
Наші соуси готує сім'я, це сімейна справа.
Все проходить через руки:
кожен помідор, перець або абрикоска.
Нам би хотілося зробити, у першу чергу,
соуси з того, що росте у нас під ногами.
Локальний продукт.
У межах, мабуть, однієї доби
на машині по наших дорогах.
Так. Все, що в Україні є: ягоди, фрукти, овочі.
Показати, що з ягід можна також зварити
не тільки джем, а ще й соус.
Я б хотіла дуже сильно, щоб мої батьки
відчували свою значущість.
Бо вони з позиції:
«Кому це треба, крім нас?
І взагалі: хто може купувати консервацію?»
І коли вони побачили, що це цікаво людям,
у них такий шок був на обличчі,
і я така думаю: «Yes!»
Знаєте? Їхня віра в себе...
Бо дуже часто нас цього не вчили,
наше покоління, а їх тим паче,
що вірити в себе і в те, що ти робиш, —
це дуже важливо.
Наше виробництво знаходиться в Жовтих Водах.
«Відвезу тебе в Жовті Води». [співає]
Є пісня. Знаєте?
— Треба послухати.
— «Там каміння червоне». [цитує пісню]
— І що?
— «І гарячі піски».
[Жовті Води,
Подніпров'я і Запоріжжя]
— Привіт!
Ідея почалася в нас у 2013 році,
фактично перші соуси
були зроблені в 2014 році.
Шість років нас знають як «Mr. Caramba».
Все почалося зі стандартних батьківських закруток,
які були нестандартні.
І вийшло так, що ми намагалися
це перевести зі звичайної
домашньої справи на більш широкий загал.
У нас ні в кого немає досвіду ведення бізнесу,
це для нас всіх нова наука.
Бувало так, що ми запускали соус,
він здавався всім класним,
ми поставили його на поличку,
а він не продавався,
бо ми елементарно не зробили правильну назву.
Ми написали «персик-хабанеро»,
а більшість людей не знала,
що таке хабанеро.
Вони купували персиковий соус,
ображались на нас,
що він — неймовірно гострий,
і тому ми його як сезон зробили,
він якось продався
і все, ми на цьому закінчили.
Тато в нас на виробництві,
можна сказати, що він — головний,
він слідкує за виконанням всіх процесів.
У мене не виходить, я психую,
приходить тато й каже:
«А може там та-та-та-та?»,
і в нас із часом все виходить.
Я впевнена, що наша якість тримається через те,
що на процесах стоять довірені люди.
Заїжджає багато овочів,
інколи це може бути 400 кілограм перцю,
і навіть сама ця думка вже не дає тобі спокою.
Ми їх після того миємо, чистимо,
ну а далі в нас переробка.
У нас тато частіше готує для соусу всі овочі,
а спеціями займається мама.
Зараз ми готуємо лагідний чилі:
ми поєднали солодкий перець, гострий перець,
свіжий імбир, сушений імбир,
цукор, сіль і оцет.
З цієї партії в нас вийде близько 100 пляшечок.
Час приготування — у середньому три години,
і ще годину буде розлив,
бо в нас це все відбувається вручну,
у нас немає лінії фасовочної машини.
Формально в нас — виробництво,
але все, як бачите, робиться вручну.
Усе проходить через наші очі.
Буває таке, що у пляшечку
потрапляє більше, ніж 300 грам,
і про це ніхто не знає,
ми скромно про це мовчимо.
Менше — не буває, а більше — буває.
Коли діти — у цеху, і дорослі зайняті
своїми дорослими справами,
є в нас процеси, які можна назвати
і дитячою роботою.
— Так? У чому ви нам допомагаєте?
— Клеїти кружéчки.
Покажете, як це робиться?
Та-дам!
Подяка. [дає п'ять]
Етикетку робила Сіма — рідна сестра Рити.
Нас всі знають за цими персонажами.
Хтось із них — мексиканець, який любить гострий перець.
Була ситуація. Дзвонить чоловік, каже:
«Я хочу замовити соус».
Ми такі: «Який?»
Він такий:
«Я не пам'ятаю, як він називається,
але там чувак тримає червоний перець».
Ми такі: «Все, зрозуміло!».
Тобто дуже приємно, що люди також
звертають увагу на якісь такі деталі,
що їм запам'ятовуються.
Взагалі, у нас можна всю продукцію
поділити на три категорії:
це ягідні — брусниця з червоним вином,
вишня та часник,
томатні і перцеві — на основі гострого перцю.
Коли ми починали, поєднання «вишня та часник» для наших людей було незрозуміле.
Ми самі всі бачимо, як останнім часом
розвивається гастрокультура,
відкриваються нові ресторани, нові поєднання,
і люди якось до цього більше адаптуються.
Можливо, через те, що більше подорожують.
Наші українці дуже часто вважають,
що італійський соус чи французький,
чи італійська ковбаса — набагато кращі за нашу.
Але насправді... Чому так?
Це наш синдром меншовартості,
тому не вистачає цього — пишатися своїм.
Перш за все, це справа,
якою займаєшся ти, твої близькі,
і ти можеш бути сам собі режисером.
Усі наші процеси — це рутина.
Я думав, що це буде прям так все «егегей-бізнес»,
насправді, це не бізнес, ти просто займаєшся
нудними-нудними справами,
які приводять тебе
до такого цікавого результату.
Кожен день — це реально важка, складна робота,
але результат, який є,
якщо його тримати завжди подумки,
то, в принципі, йти цією складною
дорогою не так уже й складно.
«Caramba» — це як ще одна дитина,
бо вона вимагає уваги, розвитку, навчання.
«Caramba» допомагає мені відчувати щастя.
Мені гордісно, що задіяна вся моя сім'я.
Я пишаюся цим!
Чесно! Дуже.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Каріна Пілюгіна]
[Режисерка
Марія Теребус]
[Режисерка монтажу
Надія Мельниченко]
[Оператори
Артем Бондаренко, Євген Царенко, Антон Векленко]
[Звукорежисер
Сергій Гусятник]
[Асистентка продюсерки
Наталія Вишинська]
[Субтитрувальниця
Оля Стулій]
[Коректорка субтитрів
Леся Любченко]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]